87 Brillas bloqueadas produce el
situación crítica en Lima y otras
regiones del Perú donde existe
desabastecimiento de alimentos y suben
los precios en dentro de toda esa
normalidad existen 140 cisternas de
combustible que están varadas en las
carreteras y estaba produciendo
desabastecimiento en las regiones del
sur Mientras tanto en ica una región
ubicada al sur de Lima el Hospital
Regional alerta que se han quedado sin
oxígeno para los pacientes y están en
una situación de urgencia Y ante todo
esto en la capital peruana los
comerciantes del Gran mercado mayorista
alertan que en las próximas 48 horas
Lima se podría quedar sin alimentos si
es que no se realiza el desbloqueo de
vías ante esta situación la presidenta
Dina boluarte ha dispuesto que la
policía y las fuerzas armadas realicen
el desbloqueo de vías precisamente esta
mañana el ministro de defensa Jorge
Chávez ha anunciado que en las próximas
horas se van a realizar operativos para
que la policía y el ejército intervengan
en los puntos críticos y liberen las
vías que se encuentran secuestradas por
los manifestantes el ministro de defensa
ha dicho que se va a realizar el
operativo siguiendo protocolos y tomando
acciones que vayan de acuerdo a las
leyes peruanas Francisco hoy El Congreso
de Perú va a debatir el adelanto de
elecciones Dina bolote está pidiendo que
se realicen en diciembre de este año qué
tan factible es esto
bueno la situación es compleja en el
parlamento peruano si bien es cierto hay
tres bancadas de derecha que apoyan que
se realice el adelanto de elecciones
este año en la primera vuelta se
realizaría en Octubre y la segunda
vuelta en diciembre de acuerdo a esta
iniciativa para que la transición de
mando el cambio de Mando se efectúe los
primeros días de enero pero también hay
congresistas de izquierda ligados al
expresidente Pedro Castillo Quienes se
oponen a la iniciativa porque señalan
que no tendría sentido adelantar las
elecciones si es que estas no van
acompañadas de una convocatoria a una
asamblea Constituyente la presidenta
Dina boluarte le hecho un llamado al
congreso para que adelante de las
elecciones se apruebe y se dé este
proyecto de ley y así sacar al Perú de
la crisis en que se encuentra Dina
boluarte les ha dicho a los congresistas
pongan fecha y hora y ella
inmediatamente convocará a nuevos
comicios en Perú